Film Courage: Okay, so the Unwritten Rules
of Hollywood, your book [HOLLYWOOD GAME PLAN:
How To Land A Job In Film, TV, and Digital
Entertainment].
Without giving away too much, from those who
have read the book, what are some takeaways
where they were completely surprised?
Whether it was a chapter, whether it was a
tip or two that you gave?
Carole Kirschner: I think that some of the
things that people came away with that they
were not expecting was that there really are
people that want to help you.
Even though there’s some…there’s some
people that would rather eat dirt than help
you.
Most people, somebody helped them, so they’re
willing to help.
I have a chapter on mentoring and how to treat
your mentor right.
And I think a lot of people didn’t understand
that you don’t go up to somebody and say
“Will you be my mentor?”
A relationship has to develop and then how
to make the ask.
I talk about the Hollywood Ask, which is a
particular kind of an ask so that you don’t
back somebody into the corner.
What people say is and these are people who
have also gone to film school is “I didn’t
understand how the business worked.
And now I understand what I should be doing,
what I shouldn’t be doing, how I should
be talking about myself.”
The whole thing about networking (and I hate
the word networking) but how you connect with
people in an authentic way so that a real
relationship forms and how that’s important
(you don’t have to be that smarmy networker).
Film Courage: Which chapter do you wish you’d
read when you first decided (I know you grew
up here in Los Angeles) but that you wanted
to be in the business?
Which chapter [in Carole’s own book] did
you say “You know what, I could have used
that 10 years ago.”
Carole Kirschner: That’s a really interesting
question.
Which of the chapters?
Now I have to think back to the chapters because
it was awhile back.
I think it was about how to prepare for meeting
and how to follow up because I didn’t know,
I didn’t know what you say to people, I
didn’t know how informal it was or how formal
it was.
I have a chapter about what to wear.
I probably would have appreciated knowing
that because you don’t know how formal or
informal you should be in what circumstance.
And also, how to connect with people.
How to meet people, what to do when you meet
them, I wish I had known that stuff.
But mostly how to behave so I didn’t put
my foot in my mouth, so I didn’t make big
mistakes.